[Music]
five years ago thanos erased half of the
population of the universe
but the people of this planet brought
everyone back with a snap of a finger
a sudden return of the population
provided the necessary energy
for the emergence to begin
how long do we have
seven days
we're eternals
we came here 7000 years ago
to protect humans from the deviants
why didn't you guys help fight thanos or
any war all the other terrible things
throughout history
[Music]
we were instructed not to interfere in
any human conflicts unless deviants are
involved
by who
[Music]
we need to find the others
i haven't seen some of them for
centuries
hi
hello
this is what the end of the world looks
like
at least we have front row seats
you know what's never saved the planet
you're sarcasm
[Music]
we have loved these people since the day
we arrived
when you love something
you protect it
[Applause]
you can't protect
[Music]
any of them
[Music]
i bet you've built the perfect safe
house what's this even made of vibranium
fall collection
ikea
[Music]
[Applause]
why does this
[Music]
is
[Music]
it's beautiful
listening
we have watched
unguided
we have helped them
progress and seen them
accomplish wonders
throughout the years
we have never interfered
until
now
[Music]
[Applause]
good
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you for this oh you are so now
that captain rogers and iron man are
both gone who do you think's gonna lead
the avengers
i could lead them
[Music]
[Music]
you